now there is another things that is a
increasing exponentially
recently in NLP which is the requirement
for more data people are using more data
for training and people are also using
more data for fine-tuning okay
so there's a problem because when you
compare two models that was they were
pre trained on two different data sets
of very different size it's really hard
to tell if one model is better because
it was betraying on more data or if it's
better because usually of the like novel
architectural design that people
introduces good a good recent example of
last year was Excel net the the
transformer from from Google
there was the successor of transformer
Excel an Excel net use a smart
autoregressive training so you could
actually do auto regressive training
while having the possibility to attend
to both contacts to left on the right
context usually when we do order
autoregressive training running or why
way so a model is masked like the right
context of each token for the model is
masked but in excel nets actually they
do auto regressive with a random
permutation so the model actually learns
to pay attention to both context now the
problem with that excel net was also
trained on a lot more data than birds so
when they compared to birds it was
really hard to tell what was the
difference what was the improvement that
came from training on 20 times more data
and which which which province came from
having this new or aggressive
architecture so there was a huge debate
and actually it was kind of settled by
Roberto which was a very simple bird
architecture that's exactly the same as
birds but just trained on more data
basically and Roberto
Alper from X on edge which showed that
basically there was the bitter lesson of
NLP and the bitter lesson of machine
learning in general as reach a certain
talk valley which is that if you have
more adam is usually out per from having
a smaller model okay and now there is
this recent people that we're going to
talk a lot more about which is called
scaling laws for a new
language model this is paper from open
AI and it's a really in-depth study of
what happened when you increase the data
size and when you increase the model
size we saw a change in the architecture
so it's very good it's very good study
now this is for pre-training
but we see the same on file journey
which is that people when they fight
hoon they do a lot of that augmentation
and a good example is the winogradsky
match challenge the winner grad scheme
at challenge was very interesting that
said for a long time it's very simple
you see one example here you have a
sentence that say for instance the
trophy would not fit in a brown suitcase
because it was too big and the question
is what was too big
was it your trophy or was it the
suitcase and the model has to do a
classification between these two one
okay so that's very interesting because
you need some common sense you need to
know that the suitcase is usually bigger
than your trophy and the way it was
solved and for a long time it was a very
hard challenge it's a very small one
you'll need like three hundred example
and for a long time it was very hard to
get good performances for deep learning
models on that and the weight was saw
was actually to generate artificial
determination that sets with some
heuristics extracting from Wikipedia
sentences where you have two times the
same noun like two times trophy
replacing one of them by it like this
you can build with these heuristics you
can build a huge data set from any any
like call text data set and you can pre
train your model on that and then you
this fine-tuning on on the Winograd
schema challenge after that and you can
solve the task but you can see that it's
not very we're not really happy about
that because scientifically we have not
really learned anything about common
sense by doing that okay we've just
around that more data is better so let's
talk a bit more about retraining first
okay so I talked about the scaling laws
paper let's go into depth in this paper
so this paper is about one single
architecture it's about the transformer
train for auto regressive language
modeling okay so you only have left
context for each token desire
some added up trying to predict the next
token given the given the beginning of
sentence this is GPT too but they
experiments with many sizes with many
sizes of the datasets and also they did
some nice scan on the architecture there
was always some question about
transformer which is what is the optimal
ratio of the number of heads we forgot
the model size what are the optimal
ratio of the number of layers we forgot
to the diamond shovel models and I can
show that all these doesn't really
matter as long as you in a like very
flat sweet point where you have this
nice high parameter that was pretty much
the original attention is own unique
parameter as long as you as you're in
this sweet spot you good so these models
are very actually rubbished
to this simple hyper parameter
exploration and what they show is that
just by scaling and model size and
scaling data set size you have a very
clear power law which mean that it's
actually exponential actually that's
what this means it's exponentially
squeezing so if you double your model
size you have this linear improvement in
performances if you double your data set
size you also have this linear
improvement but it's power low they go
over very wide ranges they go over hold
of the went on horrors of magnitude now
you can read this paper it's very
interesting they show that to to
interesting thing for me one was that
actually that was actually there was a
failure follow a paper by Eric Wallace
at UC Berkeley we show that it's
actually betters who have a too big
model it's actually better that your
model is more baby than we used to that
and then we used to to think and for the
data sets so if your model is actually
slightly too big for your data set in
the way we were assessing the size of
that's it on model before you can
actually get better results you go you
go down you know your loss go down
faster and there is another interesting
thing in this paper which is also
something we saw a little bit earlier on
the pruning which is that this
transformer models the embeddings
and the layers they behave really
differently okay so when your instance
when you prune you should prune
differently embeddings
and layers and here they show so that
it's actually the the capacity of the
model is really defined by layers and
all the power law that you observed they
work well if you remove them it is okay
if you don't take into account the
embeddings when you compute the size of
the model okay now there is a last very
interesting thing is that they have two
lows for the the decreasing glass okay
one of the laws and one of the
increasing laws one of the laws to
decrease the loss related to the
capacity of the model when you increase
the capacity of the model and one is
related to increasing the bassett both
kind of both can be related together in
terms of computation like more at time
in small computation bigger model also
means small computations you can collect
this to power low and what you see on
this graph is that you have actually two
slopes which mean that at some point
they join together and you can't really
know you don't really know what which
loss you should have okay
you have one loss which is actually
defined by our giving using the optimal
data capacity the optimal that set and
one law is defined by using the optimal
model capacity and at some point they
predict their prediction doesn't fit
together and which is actually far above
which we've been experimenting right now
it's around the pizza party pizza
parameters regime and hear what they say
that actually architecture the
transformer architecture is breaking
down that's what they open yeah okay so
all this exploration of more data and
bigger models are actually related to
one idea the idea is that maybe there
will be a qualitative jump in behavior
if we get enough data okay the idea is
like maybe just getting more data is
enough to see a qualitative like a phase
transition in how to model behave and
there is some hints of the it's a quite
interesting idea I think it's very
controversial somehow because more data
as I was the moderator become
it's really a research program right and
there's this nice paper from AI to from
Allentown more and people at an atelier
to Israel they show that actually just
comparing birds on Robertson you can you
can now you can notice a phase
transition okay so comparing Burt
Roberta is interesting because they are
the same architecture they're exactly
the same models just that Burt was
trained on only 137 billion tokens and
Roberto is trained on two point two Tara
tokens
okay so wet I was really trained on a
lot more data and here you can see this
very interesting is they were shot
evaluation so you just take the
pre-trained model you don't find you
need and you ask a question that are
kind of like the winogradsky my
challenge question okay here you ask it
a 25 year old person age is then 30 year
old person and the model has to predict
if the was younger or older so it has to
actually compare numbers together and
use some common sense if you want and
you can see that birth is pretty bad
perch is the blue curve and Rho beta
which is the green curve is actually
like super good at comparing this
remember in the in the range of ages for
people you can see the same on size
comparison if you ask Roberta to compare
the size of like the Sun to house the
table to a house and like that Roberta
is usually pretty good out of the box so
it has some form of what we would call
common sense and this is out of the box
okay just by pre-training it's also even
able to compare birth rate like birth
year sorry like if you asked if somebody
was very born in this year or this year
who is older us which means it's the
reverse than the H okay the year the
higher the your birth year of birth was
the the
younger you are and the model is able to
do this sweep swatch swap so that's very
actually surprising I think now there is
this big question when you do now
fine-tuning okay so we've seen that
retraining bigger data is just better
and actually you may even see some phase
transition now what about fine-tuning
okay so fine-tuning means you've taken
this free training model on their data
set and now you want to adapt them on
one task okay this paper is very
important one from deep mine the
evaluating learning and evaluating
general linguistic intelligence it's a
paper that can pose a lot of question
it's an opinion paper and you should
definitely read it I think if you want
it's one of the most important of last
year last year's paper it's like now I
one year old and what I say is that the
reason that said they're actually too
easy to solve with little generalization
why because we have this training data
set for the mollow that are usually
often quite be like Amanda lie or SNL I
our squad they're really kind of built
that I said to fine tune on and they
give models that actually don't really
have good sample efficiency so let's
let's focus what does this mean let's
say we have two model we have model a
model hey a as a ninety percent accuracy
with like a hundred training example but
then it doesn't get any better with more
training example okay it's it can
plateau at 90 percent model B takes like
1 million examples to get to ninety
percent accuracy but then it can
increase a little bit and it end up
plateauing at 92 percent so if we do if
we just do like we do usually like we
compare the model at the end of the
fine-tuning we will say Oh model B is
lot better because it can reach 92
percent accuracy
well actually we should really we were
Model A because model a is able to reach
very good score with just 100 training
example that's really great that's what
we wanted from transfer learning okay
that was one of the initial goal of
transfer learning was to make this model
work on very small data sets and this is
called sample efficiency it means how
better your model gets with one
additionally
sample there are a lot of other problem
with these models which are related one
model is that when you find you in on
these big data sets usually we get
models that work well really exactly on
the training on the fine-tuning domain
so you have models that work well on
squared for instance that work well that
means they work well on Wikipedia
question answering in this very narrow
field of question answering but we would
like instance we don't really want squad
models we would like to have question
answering models that would work on any
question answering tasks and this is
related to sample efficiency because it
means that if you just give a few
general question answering example you
would like your model to work already
well on them okay you would like to know
model not to need to function on full
Wikipedia to just no questions so in
Wikipedia there is a related mate matrix
matrix which is called online code
length we'd say that how much better
your model will get with each additional
sample okay it's an information theory
metric which actually is related to how
ow
how much you can compress your model so
it's a very important matrix and it's
actually probably the way to go forward
so here just a few example here you see
if a model was actually trained from so
you can see here the benefits of
transfer learning first so here on the
bottom bottom you see of birds that
strain from scratch on question
answering so this bird is not
initialized easily she is randomly
initialized okay so it's pretty bad at
the end you just train on the full
square data sets and you just don't get
very high now you can see that if bird
is pre trained already on like its usual
HP training which is the total bit
copper so we keep it yeah it goes up a
lot faster okay so this is the benefits
of transfer learning and it reached
night nice accuracy and now if you look
at this the last part which is actually
a bird that was pre trained on another
question also in that is that you can
state already start very high so it
means that this model is actually very
simple efficient
because it was already fine-tuned on
another question and asked before
okay so this model when you look at them
on online metrics online code length
metric you can see that they actually
very different because when you actually
find to this model you have to
understand the bird model was pre
trained now to fine tune it we'll add a
linear layer on top okay and this linear
layer is randomly initialized so there
is no shortcut here you will have to
train this linear layer okay you cannot
really bypass this when you use this
model with this task specific layer
added on top you need to train this task
specific layer which means that you
can't really observer hard okay and this
model we always have to catch up somehow
they always need a few example to be
able to train this last layer whatever
whatever smaller layer is this is what
we call task specific components and
that's a very strong limit to how we can
do a very simple efficient model okay
now this was just to show you when you
actually investigates sample efficiency
you can see that it's also a good way to
see if the model is actively learning
the task using the knowledge it had from
before or if it's actually learning the
task from scratch so here you see
comparison between burtom robots all
right you know that robots are we've
been showing this blue and green jaga
diagram robota has some kind of good
common sense
better than bird ok and we can see that
because when we find your robot ah it's
a lot more sample efficient with just a
few example it's already catching up
it's already getting better matrix than
Birds and by comparing the sample
efficiency curve which is the
performance of your model while you just
use progressively more more samples you
find it just by comparing the curve for
birds on rebuttal you can see I think
you can have a good idea of how much
your pre-training was helping to to get
good performance on your target tasks ok
so this paper is also
nice investigation of that and that's
actually posted a nice question of how
much that - should we need and this
actually lead us to the next topic which
is in domain versus outer domain